Ah, the worst thing you could possibly do at the moment
given that we have a Costa living crisis
and a housing crisis in this country
is to lift the rate of immigration to 500,000
people a year.
And I should add that in the last quarter,
it was actually 190,000 people
who came to Australia in the last quarter.
So that if that's extrapolated over the next 12 months,
we'll be looking at closer to 700,000 people
who are coming into this country.
Now tomorrow
it looks like the Reserve Bank of Australia
is going to raise interest rates yet again,
uh, driving more and more people into Westernity
in order to reduce the mart
because the RBA and, uh,
the former RBA governor has said this to me,
Philip Lowe,
that he only deals with the demand side of the economy.
He will not touch the supply side of the economy.
And that is why the other, uh,
point of this MPI today is cutting infrastructure,
which is what the Labour government is proposing to do
is the worst thing
or is pouring fuel onto the fire
of the immigration crisis that we have
are in this country.
And it goes to show that the Labour government
has no ideas on how to run a country.
Now, rather than raising interest rates tomorrow,
what should really happen is that the
Labour government reduces immigration.
That way hard working Australians
aren't going to get hurt
because what's happening at The moment
is that as immigration rises
it drives up demand
and then the RBA comes along
and lifts interest rates to push down demand
and that is killing
the very people that we are meant to be serving
and it's that type of mentality that has to stop.
Now the other thing is
when you have a really high immigration rate
you have to build a lot of houses
now we have an limited
number of tradies in this country
not the least because back in the 80s
under the Hawk Keating government
under the button plan ah
Labour government came up with the wonderful
idea to send everyone to university and not to TAFE
so we already have a
limited number of tradies in this country
but if they are going to build
we want them not building only houses
but we want them building houses and factories
now if we have two high immigration rate
that allocates all the labour
the tradie labour
the skilled labour
where you use your hands
from the actual building
uh factories
that could increase our manufacturing output
and start to value add
to our raw materials that we're so good at
uh producing
and I have to go into the building sector
that means we've got
most of our
you know you know
skill sector in this country
working on building houses and
and doing the plumbing and things like that for houses
instead of actually looking at improving
and getting Higher value manufacturing in this country.
So I'll conclude yet again
that the Labour government needs to get a grip.
It needs to lower immigration,
increase infrastructure spending
and start to get people back on the tools
and outer universities
and outer superannuation funds
authorized. G. Renick, LMP trimside.